the feeling of achievement it gave me
that i accomplished
that was a shot in the arm that i still
feel to this day
i've moved my whole life on instinct if
you start your day
with sweaty exercise you're actually
going to activate
a pharmacy of mastery that exists in
every human brain
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
i hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven habits that
every successful person
must have
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one trust your instincts with oprah
winfrey
i started feeling like i think everybody
knows
i i've i've moved my whole life on
instinct you know
i feel like now it's time to let the
show go i feel
like it's time to move on because i've
grown
as much as i can grow when i've grown as
much as i can grow in a space
that's my instinct to move habit number
two hustle
hard with henry rollins i had a uh
this this coach he's mentioned in that
article that you were talking about the
iron i talked about mr peppermint
yeah and he is he he i was in his car
pool he was a vietnam vet
and uh he once said to me i i have to
quote
he said uh you're a skinny little gee
thank you sir and uh he said i'm going
to teach you how to lift weights
i said okay it's more attention than my
dad gave me so i said i'll take it
and so he taught me compound lifts at
the school gym so i bought a sears and
robux sand filled weight set which i
couldn't drag to my mom's station
vw fastback and eventually i did uh
by three months of that weight set i'm
fairly throwing it across the room
because you know you're growing so fast
like your muscles are recovering
overnight you just do the same workout
every day you don't even feel it
and he said you're not allowed to look
at yourself until christmas break after
christmas exams and this was like in
september so i didn't i did everything
he told me to
and then he dropped me off before the
christmas break he said
now today you can look at yourself in
the mirror and i ran home
like ran home and i tore my stupid
school uniform off and i stood in the
mirror
and my body had definition i'm like wow
those are pecs those i mean like i look
like i was a guy who lifted some weights
and i've it was self-validating like wow
i'm here
i did that i'm looking at myself going i
did that
no one can lift those weights for you
and the feeling of achievement
it gave me that i accomplished that
was a shot in the arm that i still feel
to this day
wow i mean because it was so like wow
you can do this
that's possible right because every
other time trying to meet girls at the
school dance i had no guts to talk to
the girls so they were alien creatures
um i didn't do well in school so you
could make fun of me i couldn't throw
the ball straight so they would throw it
at my head to watch me run
and so i it didn't have any traction
anywhere
and then when i had the weights i'm like
wow
i'm filling out my t-shirt man
noticeable improvement hell yeah i mean
plus effort equals results and i
couldn't
didn't make my grades better cause i
still it was all of swahili to me is
schooling was a slip too
it was probably too late i just yeah i
was not good at sitting still
but when i had the summer jobs that's
when i kicked ass
i never had an allowance i never my mom
said you never said here's 20 bucks i'm
like where'd henry go he's got three
jobs over the weekend
i'd wake up in the morning go to the pet
shop work all day there
run home shower change my clothes do the
night shift at the movie theater
take the bus out to the surf shop in the
suburbs and
repair skateboards and whatever on
sundays so i always had
pocket money because i always i liked
having working a cash register
on my keychain in school i had the keys
to stores
bosses trusted me because i'd never
steal and i
so i would work like like 20 hours a
week and go to school
in high school and part of that was
informed by the weightlifting and
i like getting out of the house and
being responsible but in school it
didn't mean much to me but
showing up on time at the pet shop and
cleaning out 20 cat pans man that was
like
i had to be there at 8 o'clock not 801
man
because we got things to do i felt a
real fealty
and to this day like if i'm ever on a
film shoot like who's the guy who's
there early man that's me i'm i'm there
i memorized the whole damn script
i'm so happy to have a job i'm like
amazed anyone cares
and so all of that uh it keeps me on the
straight and narrow because i i
i call myself a human frozen yogurt
machine just output
you know i don't want the applause i
don't i like to build chips i don't want
to sail in them
and the best part about finishing the
ship is it sails
off to sea and you can build another so
i love finishing a book
you know get this thing off my desktop
now i can start a new one like where can
i go now
and so that's how i i live to achieve
and to output but it's not i don't
ever look at i have a thing on my
computer
it's called the list and i keep a list
of like every show
uh every book i've written every movie
i've been in every album i've ever made
and when you look at it
it's intense it's like you keep a list
of every show you've ever done
oh hell yeah of course wow of course i
don't know anybody who does that
yeah and sometimes i write down uh the
set length
i take a lot of notes wow oh yeah write
them all down but um i have this one
thing called the list
and it's just like you know every film
every tv show every voiceover
um every book every record on on and on
and sometimes i look at it just have to
input like the new book comes out i have
to go to the thing in input and i look
at this list and my bones start aching
i'm like man this is a lot of there's a
lot of a lot of crap this came out yeah
and i don't wave it around and goes see
what i've done i just kind of go i'm
only interested in what i'm doing what
i'm doing next
habit number three establish habits for
seeking clarity with brendan burchard
in terms of clarity what is that habit
that you take on on a daily or
monthly basis with habit with clarity
what do you think about you're like
every morning what am i clear about or
yeah you know how do you apply that
habit to your life
i apply in a couple ways first for me
every situation i go into i'm
consistently asking like what
what's the feeling i want to have here
if you ever
see me teach it's often i always say
bring the joy so i have joy triggers
that i've set up in my mind that makes
me more intentional
about things so for example a door frame
trigger whenever i walk through a door
i say bring the joy so when i walk
through that door right there it's like
bring the joy into this room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that i've set up for myself
every morning in the shower i ask myself
three questions
and not that i shower every morning
the first question i say what can i be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw
joy enthusiasm for me number two i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what what might mess me
up what my
where might i perform well what might
bother me and number three i say what
can i do
to surprise somebody today to give a
gift of appreciation or acknowledgement
today
and so i think through that in the
morning so i think that helps me begin
my day pretty clear
then when i sit down before i do work i
literally look at my calendar of the day
this morning and i look at whatever's
going on the day and i think about for
20 minutes
it's one of my 20 minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar for 20 minutes a
day
people think that's crazy but what i'm
thinking through when i'm looking to
count i'm like okay i'm gonna have that
call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call
you know i'm gonna have that time with
louis like how do i
want to be there and and and how can i
make sure i enjoy it because it's a big
deal
you know i love your show i want to do a
good job i want to
share something good for the people even
though i have no idea what you're going
to ask right
i want to be present for that and and
make sure i i'm
i'm really there even though maybe i
have a head cold today you know it's
like
it's like just thinking through it i
think that helps me
it keeps me asking questions every
sunday i do a life arenas assessment
that just means i think there's 10 areas
of our life and
i score myself in them and this is about
my 11th year of doing this wow
so each area of my life you know from
from emotional quality
to happiness to relationships to time to
hobby etc
i just give myself a score of one to ten
and one means i
suck and i i was horrible in the
previous week on that 10 means i did a
good job
and then i asked how can i do better
it's my sunday routine yeah and it just
keeps me clear
and it's not like i don't sometimes like
everyone else
you know wonder what's going on or what
i'm doing but
those habits those were my habits you
have to establish your own for seeking
clarity but when you have them
you weaponize your life all right my
friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
habit number four optimize your energy
with robin sharma
one of the lines from right out of the
5am club is
one of the dnas of legendary is
longevity
so if you look at the picassos the
jean-michel basquiat you look at the
great
sports champions you look at the great
history makers
they were much better at energy
management than time management
and so we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is
optimize our energy how do i do it well
i mean i get to the morning routine
which
which the whole book is based on but
it's really quite powerful because if
you start your day
with sweaty exercise you're actually
going to activate
a pharmacy of mastery that exists in
every human brain
i know you love the neuroscience you're
going to release bdnf which is
brain-derived neurotrophic factor
that's going to actually accelerate your
processing it's actually going to repair
brain cells that have been damaged by
stress you're going to release
the neurotransmitter dopamine which is
the the
fire neurotransmitter which we all need
as entrepreneurs and business builders
and
and servants of humanity cortisol
the fear hormone is highest in the
morning so
exercising first thing in the morning is
going to reduce that i'm getting into my
20 20 20 formula but i mention it
because it is a way to maximize your
energy
before the sun rises it's the time of
least distraction
before the sun rises where you can build
intimacy and fluency with what you want
to stand for
in your day before the sun rises the
luxury and tranquility of the early
morning hours
you can do that deep inner work that
will allow you to go out in the world
and and play at your best so what the 20
20 20 formula is is simply this there's
three pockets the first pocket is move
five to five twenty and you get into the
sweaty exercise because like i mentioned
it releases
uh neurotransmitters it reduces the
cortisol
increases your metabolic rate which
gives you more energy so now and
serotonin as well which gives you joy
so now it's 5 20. fundamentally you feel
different you have
energy your state is strong you've got a
fire in your belly and you've
accelerated your focus 520 to 540 is the
second pocket
of the 20 20 20 formula which is reflect
we live in a world where a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being
busy around climbing the wrong mount
everests
and so clarity is one of the dnas of
mastery
you know this if you talk to the titans
of industry and you talk to the people
really getting traction around their
ambition
these are people who have a monomaniacal
focus on the few things that matter
they have an obsession bordering on a
possession around the few priorities
they want to build their life around and
so 520 to
540 the second pocket you write in a
journal
you meditate you visualize
you do what i call in the book a
blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect
and then the final pocket is 5 40 to 6
o'clock and this is the victory hour
the final pocket is grow but if you look
at the greatest billionaires i've
coached many billionaires over the past
20 years if you look at the greatest
producers on the planet these people
have one thing in common they are
ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
and no matter how much impact they have
they maintain a white belt mentality one
of the keys to epic performance
is a relentless commitment to daily
growth so that's the 20 20 20 formula
that the 5 a.m method is built around
and the premise is basically this as you
begin your day so you hand craft the
rest of your day
and if you have consistently great days
you're going to have consistently great
weeks
quarters a year and a lifetime so your
days are
life and miniature and you've got to get
those mornings calibrated if you really
want to win
how about number five find the good with
dean graziosi
find the good now find the good what
does that have to do with making more
money here's why
i know unsuccessful people figure out
what's wrong with the world
figure out why people are holding them
back figure out why the advice they got
is bad
figure out why the president is bad or
the economy is bad or where they live is
bad
and it's like our subconscious is
designed for that so i want to just
throw that away i want to give you a new
rule like
you've heard this before but maybe right
now is the first time you ever
really heard it and you decide to
implement it in your life
if you want that life you crave so find
the good
you see it's really easy to find what's
wrong with the world we know that
it's really easy to find what's wrong
with the people around you
but what if you shifted that framework
and your obsession was to find what's
right
to find what's good to look for the good
in people
rather than bad to look for the good in
the marketing strategies that you're
working on look
for the good in your family even though
they're a pain in the ass sometimes but
they're trying to protect you
as simple as this little shift sound
you're like oh dean i thought you were
going to tell me how to make money i am
i am telling you how to make money and
i'm telling you how to be happy and i'm
telling you how to thrive when other
people struggle and when the economy
turns like it's gonna
you could be the one ahead because
you're gonna have to find the good when
the whole world is finding what's wrong
so one simple hack today this week
obsess on looking for the good how about
number six
adjust your set points with john ashraf
talk to me about set points that was
something
really interesting in what you talk
about around
the stories and things that we carry
that i found really interesting sure so
maxwell maltz wrote a great book many
many years ago in the probably the 70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell moss was a
surgeon who performed surgery on people
and what he notices even after
plastic surgery that he performed on
people some people
didn't see any change in their faces and
it was visible to everybody else but not
to them
because they had a map of what they
thought they look like yes okay
so we all have a map of reality
we have a map of what we think we look
like
and any deviation on the physical level
to that
map to that visual representation we
have in our brains
that doesn't match the map your brain
deletes or distorts it
so when we were working with real estate
or when i worked with business owners
in addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have set points for how much income
we earn so whether it's 10 000 a year or
20 or 50 or 100 or a million it doesn't
matter
we get this set point and then we behave
the way we need to behave and we feel
what we need to feel to earn that income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode network
so we develop set points for everything
and so
if the set point's in the brain and
there's a psycho-cybernetic mechanism
in the brain a control and response
mechanism in the brain
and it's our brain why not learn
how to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that
what evidence-based methods are there to
set that
or to reset that and so when we take
let's say visualization right and you
start to see yourself even if the
picture's not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success
whether it's releasing weight and
keeping it off getting into a
relationship that you love and are happy
and whether it's to make
two or three or five times more money
and live a certain type of lifestyle
that allows you to do the things
that freedom with having money allows
you to do
if you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside
out so use both i want every advantage
and habit number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is develop your self-awareness with jim
quick
dude i'm a huge believer in identity
driving
behaviors um i have a hard time
explaining to people though how to adopt
a new identity how do you how have you
done it in your own life i think that's
the best
i mean my identity i mean obviously this
is a work in progress right
um i would say that i would start with
the
they call it the two smallest world
words in the english language
but they're their two most powerful
words in the english language it's i
am right i am because whatever you put
after that determines your
destination or your your destiny right
and i think
your identity is who you believe you are
and i feel like
when we're talking about playing to the
edge of our limits and really playing
there and
living in that place where we're
stretching you know i do believe and i
get inspired every time i see your insta
story you're like it's like 4 30 and
you're working out you're doing
your work but that's who you are right
you don't have to fight it because you
can't
imagine yourself not doing that and
that's the level of
that i that i think is what's most
important so i would think about
going through an exercise and i've done
this with friends i've had them sit
or in groups we do these conferences and
such and i find
i have people pair up with someone they
don't know and what they're going to do
is they're going to do an exercise i am
and they're going to talk a bit they're
literally going to fill in the blanks
for three minutes until i call time
so you have to go like and you can do
this right now like if you were to fill
in i am blank like i would say
you know i am a student i am a teacher i
am a son i'm a
you know all this and but eventually
i'll get to a point where i don't know
what else to say
and that's what the real interesting
answers come out of
right because it's a great way for
networking and knowing somebody else
but it also shows us this really big
tapestry of our life to the point that
we've content
right now where we could i relate to
these aspects of ourselves
and i think it's a nice exercise when we
talk about self-awareness being a
superpower really knowing
who we think we are because if we don't
believe that we're our public speaker or
we're a great parent or we're a great
learner or a genius
then we'll never be able to reach our
full potential because that will always
be the ceiling that we bump
up against now i've got a special bonus
clip on how to raise
your standards that i think you're going
to enjoy but before that it's time for
the question of the day
i want to know from the seven habits
that we just talked about
what's the one that's most important to
you right now in your life for business
let me know your answer put it down in
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag
believe down in the comments and tell me
where you're from cause i want to
celebrate
you you are a product of your
environment
the people around you are keeping you
exactly where you are
and if you love where you are then keep
with those people
but if you want more out of life if
you've got bigger dreams bigger
ambitions
then you're going to have to let some of
those takers go
now i'm pretty fortunate that i haven't
had any real takers in a long time in my
life
but here's the thing it's easy to
recognize the people who are really
negative in your life and want to
eliminate them
but then once you've done that you'll
still find that there's this middle
ground there's these people who bring
you energy who are amazing who lift you
up or austin be around
and they're people who are negative that
you cut out of your life but then
there's that middle ground of people who
they're just okay they're not bad
they're not great
it's just okay and if you want to raise
the quality of your life
if you want to raise your standards you
can't be hanging around at least
spending most of your time
with people who make you feel just okay
so i got back from an event with tony
robbins
not that long ago i think it was last
year when i went with my friend mark
draker
and tony at the end of his events how's
you do this fire walk
and he lays out these you know coals
these hot burning coals
across the parking lot and you have to
walk uh walk over and he has to sing
cool moss cool moss and it gets you all
excited and amped up to ready to cross
the walk and the idea is you're doing
something that you're afraid of you're
doing something that
you're scared of and to show yourself
that you're capable of doing difficult
things
mark and i decided to actually skip the
fire walk
because we rushed home and i did the
real fire walk which was in my life
letting go of a number of people who
were just okay
it wasn't that they were bad or toxic or
big takers from my life
it was just okay and i realized if i'm
spending all my time on things that are
just
okay things people projects ideas that
are just okay that make you feel
just okay right it's good is the enemy
of great if it's really bad you're gonna
let it go but if it's good you just keep
it around
and then suddenly the good becomes your
standard your good becomes acceptable
when did good become acceptable that's
what you need to draw the line in the
sand and see the ideas that are just
good i need to eliminate from my life
the people that are just
good i need to either eliminate or spend
less time with them to leave
room for the things that are great
extraordinary excellent
raising your standards making you
believe more in yourself and your
capabilities
and so coming back from that event not
even it was on that day
not even coming back was on that day i
went back to my airbnb
with mark and and i let go of
multiple people in my life and not let
go and say you suck just
basically moving on and and that allowed
me to have a lot more momentum now now i
had a lot more free time that allowed me
to focus on things
that would build me up that would
explode my growth forward and it's been
a crazy
year it's been it's been basically a
year november
2018 was when that happened so now it's
been almost a full year
uh i guess by the time this video comes
out it's been a full year wow that's
crazy
it's been a full year since i have you
have to let go of the takers first and
then you have to start thinking about
are the people around you just good are
your ideas just good and slowly start
getting rid of those ones the projects
the tasks look
your calendar what's just good in your
life and get rid of it
and leave room and focus on the things
that are extraordinary that fill you up
that build you up to make you feel
amazing
because you deserve it and all of your
great work all of your great activities
all of your great momentum
your great impact is going to come on
the other side of doing amazing things
you will never create something amazing
when you're working on something good
when you feel
good and definitely not when you feel
bad
[Music]
if you want more wisdom on building
successful habits check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if i didn't train as much as i did
i'm 70 years old i wouldn't look like i
look
and i don't feel 70. people tell me i
don't look 70.